[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Sébastien Chenu bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous député du Nord
vice-président du rassemblement national
et vice-président de l'Assemblée
nationale on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
bonjour Fabrice le saint Renaud bonjour
Oriane bonjour Sébastien
ces derniers jours à l'empe p12a
Sébastien Chenu Giorgia Meloni et on
Soula vanderleyan était ensemble hier
sur cette île italienne la présidente de
la Commission européenne qui a appelé
les pays européens à accueillir des
migrants pour soulager l'Italie alors
que des milliers de migrants débarqués à
l'anpedouza ces derniers jours que doit
faire la France elle doit dire non oui
la France doit dire non c'est une
histoire sans fin dans laquelle l'Union
européenne nous entraîne cette volonté
qui n'a pas de fin en soi parce que le
problème de l'immigration le problème
des migrations sont devant nous et bien
ne peut pas être solutionné par un
accueil
répéter sans fin de ces populations
parce que nous courons un risque
évidemment de déstabilisation nous avons
une incapacité d'assimilation et ceci il
faut laisser l'Italie toute seule
aujourd'hui la solidarité avec l'Italie
dans ce que disent dans ce qu'appelle
aujourd'hui vendeur Layenne ça veut dire
en fait accueillir des migrants et les
répartir dans l'Union européenne donc ce
n'est pas ça il y a des solutions de
court terme il y a des solutions de long
terme je vais y revenir si vous le
souhaitez mais l'idée que le
l'hémisphère sud que l'Afrique depuis ce
déménager dans l'Europe n'est pas un
projet ça ne peut pas être un projet il
faut aider les pays là-bas à avoir un
avenir ça c'est sur la philosophie il y
a des solutions à court terme
aujourd'hui parce que évidemment
l'Italie a une frontière avec la France
il va falloir immédiatement surveiller
cette frontière entre l'Italie et la
France notamment ce qu'on appelle la
bande des 25 km autour de la frontière
avoir des la capacité d'avoir des
centres de attention s'il y avait une
arrivée immédiate de migrants de
traitement des dossiers d'asile
immédiates s'ils étaient demandés pour
notre pays donc il faut évidemment
préserver la France de cela mais il faut
aussi changer complètement de politique
migratoire c'est à dire qu'il faut
l'Union européenne n'a pas vocation car
elle a été mandatée par personne à
s'occuper des politiques migratoires
personne n'a demandé aucun peuple n'a
demandé à l'Union européenne de
s'occuper de l'immigration il y a un
traité qui Amsterdam il y a un espace
qui est Schengen ça c'est sur la libre
circulation et il y a beaucoup à dire
beaucoup à faire là-dessus mais personne
n'a demandé à l'Union européenne de
décider de qui pouvait venir en France
sur le court terme qu'est-ce qu'on fait
de ces milliers de migrants on les
laisse en Italie il faut les reconduire
dans leur port d'origine les traiter
nous oblige à prendre soin et tant mieux
de ces pauvres ères qui arrivent sur nos
côtes mais elle est reconduire dans des
ports sur 90% mais 90% reviennent de
Tunisie donc il faut les ramener dans ce
pays qui n'est pas en guerre la Tunisie
n'est pas un pays en guerre c'est un
pays qui a des difficultés économiques
m'écoutez alors à ce moment là on
accepte tout on ouvre tout et nous
n'avons plus aucune souveraineté
Sébastien Chenu vous êtes plutôt proche
politiquement d'elle le programme
c'est ça en matière économique
internationale fait preuve de votre
discours dans sa campagne quand même
ce que vous dites est intéressant ça
veut dire que les gens qui essayent de
copier un discours notamment celui
peut-être du rassemblement
elle a eu des propos incantatoires et
derrière elle n'a pas été capable où
elle n'a pas souhaité ce qui est une
déception absolue et mettre en oeuvre
donc alors que c'est génial
était sur place elle se trompe dans la
méthode oui elle se tromper évidemment
dans la méthode faire appel à l'Europe
venir pleurer le secours de l'Union
européenne évidemment pas la bonne
solution
ce qu'il faut c'est que les nations et
Meloni devraient être le faire de lance
de cette politique reprenne le contrôle
des politiques migratoires et donc des
frontières si d'ailleurs vous avez vous
avez des
vous vous dites il faut regarder 12 ans
il faut regarder ce qui se passe à
Lampedusa parce que c'est ce qui risque
d'arriver dans les prochaines années en
France est-ce que vous avez dit ce que
le rassemblement national 18e est-ce que
ce que fait genre jameloni c'est pas
aussi la preuve de l'échec de vos
politiques si jamais vous arrivez au
pouvoir regarder ce que fait un pays
comme le Danemark qui a activé ce qu'on
appelle l'option de retraite pour par
les Français le Danemark a une politique
extrêmement stricte en matière
d'immigration il a vu passer son nombre
de demandes d'asile à 80 000 alors
qu'elles étaient je crois à plus de
200000 par an il a une politique de
maîtrise de ces de de sa politique
migratoire effectivement c'est dissonant
est-ce que c'est comparable le problème
le contrôle d'une politique migratoire
qui encore une fois je le redis n'a pas
été délégué à l'Union européenne l'Union
européenne et nous le contestons n'a pas
à se mêler des politiques migratoires
des États souverains et bien des bateaux
qui viennent sans lait pour comment vous
vous arrêtez et l'Union européenne et
l'Union européenne sa seule vocation
devrait être d'appliquer le retour de
ces bateaux dans leur port d'origine là
l'Union européenne pourrait se mobiliser
dans la lutte contre les passeurs au
lieu d'avoir transformé Frontex en une
espèce d'agence d'hôtesse d'accueil des
migrants et bien l'Union européenne
pourrait mettre des moyens pour
arraisonner ces bateaux les ramener dans
le respect des problèmes de l'Union
européenne non mais pour les ramener
dans leur pays d'origine ce qui est
totalement l'inverse de ce que l'Union
européenne fait puisque mais
entendons-nous l'Union européenne non
seulement je trouve à une et coupable
d'une politique migratoire totalement
délirante qu'elle assume qu'elle
revendique puisque madame disait le 15
septembre on a besoin d'une main
d'oeuvre
migrantes écoutez c'est totalement
délirant donc elle assume une politique
migratoire et puis elle se retrouve
confronté à la souveraineté des peuples
qui disent notamment l'Italie par
exemple ici nous on ne peut plus ou
l'Allemagne qui dit non nous on a on
accueillera plus c'est fini on a donné
donc cette histoire c'est sans fin parce
que si on continue dans la logique de la
même manière et l'Union européenne et
bien ce sont des milliers des centaines
de milliers de migrants qui seront de
venir ou de travail en Europe ou de
simplement la traversée pour aller dans
des pays dont il juge la législation
plus accueillante en termes du travail
notamment le Royaume-Uni donc il va
falloir un moment se mettre autour d'une
table et c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin
aussi d'avoir des députés européens qui
n'ont pas le même discours qui forme une
autre majorité demain au Parlement
européen
les proches d'Emmanuel Macron notamment
Pierre-Alexandre en gladière qui prenait
la parole président de la commission des
affaires européennes de l'Assemblée ils
disent le ratio rassemblement national
bloque justement le pacte européen sur
l'immigration parce que je le cite ils
sont comme les passeurs ils vivent de la
misère ils sont les passeurs de la vie
politique
ceux qui vivent de la misère ce sont
ceux qui sont aux commandes et au levier
depuis 30 ans et notamment monsieur
Anglade et ses amis parce que
aujourd'hui avec les politiques que nous
connaissons ça incite non seulement des
ONG qui sont compliqués c'est un rapport
de qui le dit qui sont complices de
passeurs ça invite et un site de pauvres
migrants à traverser la Méditerranée
pensant qu'il y a un eldorado de l'autre
côté beaucoup périssent en Méditerranée
c'est-à-dire que ces politiques non
seulement il déstabilisent les pays
d'accueil mais elles ont pour résultat
la mort de milliers de migrants qui
trouve la mort dans la Méditerranée donc
monsieur Anglade devrait prendre ses
responsabilités lui et ses amis et se
rendre compte que non seulement leur
politique et déstabilisantes pour les
pays d'accueil mais les particulièrement
inhumaine pour les intéresser eux-mêmes
donc nous nous proposons autre chose
nous proposons que les bandes d'asile se
fasse dans des pays de départ ou des
pays sur si le pays lui-même est
déstabilisé le pays d'à côté nous avons
je le rappelle en ce qui concerne la
France un réseau d'ambassade et de
consuls qui permet cela dépays le font
je citais tout à l'heure le Danemark
c'est sa politique de faire faire les
demandes d'asile dans les pays de départ
nous considérons qu'elles doivent être
examinées là-bas avant d'autoriser
quelqu'un à venir et si quelqu'un vient
en France sans avoir un en règle et bien
il ne pourra plus en avoir dans l'avenir
nous considérons que là aussi parce que
Schengen permet de passer d'un pays à
l'autre ça c'est valable pour les
Européens très bien pas de problème mais
lorsqu'on est pas un citoyen européen on
devrait avoir un visa pour traverser un
pays passer de l'Allemagne à la France
ou de la France au Portugal à l'Espagne
etc que soit valable pour les Européens
la libre circulation très bien mais les
autres devraient avoir un visa sinon il
y a plus de droits d'asile possible
Marine Le Pen elle propose une
déclaration des droits des nations et
des peuples qu'est-ce que c'est
exactement c'est un frexit déguisé non
pas du tout c'est une façon de rappeler
que lorsqu'un État parle lorsqu'un État
souverain prend la parole il doit être
écouté et respecté en particulier au
sein de l'Union européenne nous nous
trouvons et on le voit avec le pacte
d'immigrations
ont des souverainetés sont souverains et
doivent non ça veut dire que les États
sont souverains notamment dans les
politiques qui ne sont pas définies par
l'Union européenne et on repart
effectivement de ce côté-là sur les
politiques migratoires n'est pas
seulement ça veut dire aussi que les
États sont souverains face aux
influences que peuvent avoir par exemple
les Gafa ça veut dire que les étapes
doivent pouvoir avoir le dernier mot sur
un certain nombre de politiques qui
concernent leur population les intérêts
économiques les intérêts
sociaux de nos pays sont parfois
divergents nos équilibres économiques
sont divergents sont différents et on ne
peut pas demander la même chose
c'est-à-dire par exemple remettre en
cause le système des retraites en France
et demander que les Français ont soit
heureux ce n'est pas à l'Union
européenne de nous demander de remettre
en cause notre système de retraite nous
l'avons bâti et construit par conséquent
ça remet j'allais dire l'église au
milieu du village ce traité ça permet de
rappeler sans quoi les pays sont
souverains une dernière question sur
l'immigration Fabrice
écoutez quelle mesure vous allez
proposer dans la loi immigration mais
vous savez elles sont très claires parce
que la première des choses nous
demandons un référendum nous nous
considérons que c'est aux Français de
s'exprimer sur ce qu'ils veulent ou pas
en matière migratoire est-ce qu'ils
veulent une immigration de quota est-ce
qu'ils veulent une immigration dans
laquelle on revoit et on restreint par
exemple le droit d'asile combien de
temps on peut se maintenir en France
nous nous proposons cela nous proposons
qu'on revoit drastiquement la politique
migratoire dans notre pays je ne vois
pas de texte mais peut-être ici au Sénat
le voyez-vous je ne vois toujours pas de
texte arriver à l'Assemblée nationale
nous on est tout à fait disposés et
disponible avec les 88 députés du
rassemblement national aujourd'hui à
traiter ce débat avant les élections
européennes à le mettre dans la lumière
d'une campagne
oui enfin ça fait un an qu'on nous
bassine avec ça ça fait un an qu'on nous
dit que le texte va arriver il n'est
toujours pas là traitons-le avant les
élections européennes ça permettra une
bonne et saine information des Français
et vous voulez faire de ces européennes
un référendum pour contamination oui
mais aussi plus largement un référendum
sur la politique
menée par Emmanuel Macron c'est la seule
élection de mi-mandat les élections
européennes elles se déroulant le 9 juin
c'est l'élection de mi-mands
c'est le seul moment où les Français
vont pouvoir dire à mi-mandat ce qu'ils
pensent des politiques qui sont menées
des politiques européennes on a dit qui
entraîne beaucoup d'élection de
mi-mandat et d'en faire un référendum
sur l'immigration c'est pas aussi une
sorte de facilité pour vous parce que
vous n'êtes pas très à l'aise sur les
sujets de l'Europe c'est plutôt un
risque que nous prenons parce que nous
allons demander aux Français de se
prononcer sur ces politiques qui
entravent beaucoup leur vie l'énergie
c'est l'Europe les politiques
migratoires on le voit c'est l'Europe
donc on demande aux Français de se
prononcer sur le projet va porter Jordan
Bardella mais celui d'une nouvelle
majorité au sein d'Union Européenne mais
aussi sur les politiques qui sont menées
et qui impactent durement la vie des
Français dans leur quotidien justement
on va parler de la vie des Français dans
leur quotidien on va parler de l'in
flation enfin bref
la vente à perdre sur les carburants
sera autorisé pour que les prix puissent
baisser est-ce que vous voterez cette
mesure Sébastien Chenu non mais cette
mesure va amener de choses les grands
groupes à s'en mettre plein les poches
et ensuite les stations essence
indépendantes à fermer ça on continue
d'ailleurs dans une sorte d'ubérisation
de la société à laquelle Macron et ses
ministres nous ont habitués
pour les grands groupes rien pour les
PME les TPE et cette disposition qui est
la seule annonce aujourd'hui moi je suis
pas favorable on va regarder ce qu'il y
a dans le texte mais est-ce qu'on vote
ça parce qu'on veut des mesures pérennes
on veut des choses qui durent dans le
temps on nous a expliqué madame borne
nous a expliqué longtemps abandon baisse
pas les taxes parce que les taxes
d'abord ça peut faire baisser la
consommation et donc c'est bien pour
l'écologie ce n'est jamais arrivé la
consommation d'énergie d'essence en
particulier ne baisse pas parce que tout
simplement les gens ont besoin de leur
voiture pour aller travailler je
regardais il y a 7 fois plus de
covoiturage pour les ouvriers que pour
les cadres c'est à dire qu'effectivement
quand on va travailler quand on va
travailler à l'usine et bien on a besoin
de sa voiture et on fait du covoiturage
donc pas cette mesure alors qu'elle doit
normalement permettre aux Français de
payer le recensement cher non mais
écoutez cette mesure c'est du baratin
cette mesure le problème c'est ce sont
les marches que font les grands groupes
et ce sont les taxes nous on souhaite
une mesure baisse de taxes
un effort en fait mais non seulement
c'est à l'état de faire un effort parce
que l'énergie c'est un bien de première
nécessité comme sur les produits de
première nécessité sur lequel on demande
aussi des baisses de taxes mais
d'ailleurs pour l'instant vous avez
demandé une TV à 0 % bon vous avez une
receveur qui vous dit de revoir vos
dossiers oui mais parce que Madame borne
elle voit les choses comme une comptable
nous on voit les choses comme des
solutions pour sortir les Français de la
difficulté les études trouvent que c'est
pas c'est bien souvent pas répercuté sur
les prix au Portugal c'est quand même
pas très loin le Portugal a fait une
baisse de la TVA sur les produits de
première nécessité ils viennent de la
reconduire pourquoi parce que c'est un
effet endominaux qui fait que ça fait
baisser les prix de l'ensemble des prix
de l'alimentaire je vous rappelle que
sur l'alimentaire les Français se sont
restreints il y a une baisse de 10% de
la consommation de l'alimentaire
alexandre Bompard le PDG de Carrefour
qui n'est pas suspecté d'être proche du
rassemblement national parle de
sous-consommation alimentaire il dit
qu'il y a que les Français consomment
moins parce qu'ils en ont moins les
moyens il y a trois leviers la baisse
des taxes sur l'énergie la baisse des
taxes sur les produits de première
nécessité mais aussi une hausse des
salaires nous on le dit de 10% concertés
avec les entreprises en échange de
quelle on ferait un gel de cotisations
patronales et bien madame borne au lieu
de faire de la comptabilité de favoriser
les grands groupes être mieux de réunir
les entreprises de réunir les grands
syndicats patronaux et d'aller vers
cette augmentation des salaires c'est ça
redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux Français
c'est ça donner de l'oxygène
pour augmenter les salaires des Français
si Madame borne nous dit demain
j'augmente selon la proposition du
rassemblement national les salaires de
10% en échange d'une baisse d'un gel des
cotisations patronales l'augmentation
des salaires ça dépend mais il initié
quelque chose il faut qu'elle prenne la
main madame borne qu'elle arrête d'être
dans son côté à faire de la comptabilité
pour favoriser les grands groupes il
faut redonner de l'oxygène aux Français
du pouvoir d'achat aux Français
immédiatement on parlait d'un autre
sujet c'est le harcèlement scolaire
Gabriel Attali l'éducation nationale à
qualifié de honte la réponse du rectorat
aux parents du jeune Nicolas qui alerté
sur le harcèlement scolaire que subit
leur fils est-ce que vous demandez des
sanctions fermes ceux qui ont quitté
l'initiative de cette
missive qui a été envoyée aux parents et
totalement déplacé totalement
scandaleuse et je me demande d'ailleurs
dans quel esprit un moment on peut
envoyer quel esprit pond une telle
réponse à des parents qui sont dans la
douleur
mais au-delà de ça sur la problématique
du harcèlement en 2019 si ma mémoire est
bonne Emmanuel Macron disait qu'il
fallait mettre en place des politiques
de lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
en étant 2023 il semblerait Gabriel
Attal commence à ouvrir le dossier
c'est un gouvernement pour le pour le
coup qui ne prend pas qui prend le temps
on va dire de regarder les choses alors
que nous par exemple je pense à Kevin
mauvieux et à moi-même on a déposé des
propositions de loi sur le harcèlement
scolaire moi je serais ravi que Gabriel
Attal s'empare de ce que nous proposons
ce que nous proposons c'est prévenir
responsabiliser éloigné sanctionner
prévenir parce que nous pensons que
cette le travail de l'État et de la
communauté éducative que de prévenir
éloigner le harceleur sanctionner
responsabilités
harceleur qui quitte son établissement
scolaire et non plus l'élève c'est ce
qu'on a proposé il y a déjà quelques
mois bien avant la rentrée évidemment et
Gabriel Attal a eu probablement
s'inspirer de ce que nous faisons parce
que je note que Gabriel Attal s'inspire
beaucoup de ce que nous faisons il va
rarement vous mais il trouve qu'on a des
bonnes idées elle retourne l'autorité
avec Gabriel Attal euh l'uniforme qui va
être expérimenté la convocation directe
on sent on sent que Gabriel Attal
aimerait appliquer ce que nous proposons
l'interdiction de la Bayard le retour de
l'uniforme les sanctions sur le
harcèlement on sent qu'il est très
inspiré ira-t-il jusqu'au bout nous on
ne fait jamais la politique du pire si
ça va dans le bon sens on soutiendra on
a soutenu d'ailleurs la fin de la Bayane
l'interdiction de la Baya dans les
écoles parce qu'on considère que ça va
dans le bon sens sur l'uniforme on va
plus loin notre mère de Perpignan oui à
mère et reine non seulement fait une
expérimentation dans sa ville sur la
base du volontariat il y a je crois une
école au minimum qui est portée
volontaire et dans lequel on va
expérimenter le port de la tenue
uniforme donc ça veut dire que nous on
va jusqu'au bout on ne se contente pas
de discours j'ai le sentiment que
Gabriel Attal aujourd'hui est beaucoup
dans la communication beaucoup dans le
discours ira-t-il au bout sur ces élèves
harceleur il faut aller encore plus loin
est-ce qu'il faut les sortir du système
scolaire classique et les mecs par
exemple dans des établissements
spécialisés éducatifs spécialisés
effectivement une échelle de sanctions
qui passe par la sortie momentanée ou
définitive selon les cas et les
principaux sont les plus à même de juger
et puis effectivement un passage dans
des structures qui permettent à ces
jeunes gens de prendre conscience de ce
qu'ils ont fait en tous les cas c'est au
harceleur d'être sorti du système
scolaire et pas à l'élève qui est
harcelé prévenir responsabilité
éloigné sanctionner cette 4
voies dans lesquelles il faut aller là
encore vous savez qu'après la taille il
a juste à prendre notre proposition de
loi elle est prête moi je l'ai déposé
Kevin mauvieux député de l'heure la
déposé aussi on a déposé une aussi c'est
facile de s'inspirer des travaux que
nous avons fait parce que nous avons eu
une année de travail à l'Assemblée
nationale pour proposer ce genre de
dispositif le 12 octobre prochain ce
sera votre niche et vous allez défendre
entre autres un texte pour soutenir les
femmes qui souffrent d'endométriose
Clémentine autant député à la fille
demande au ministre de la Santé d'agir
en urgence pour vous couper l'herbe sous
le pied elle dénonce une opération
grossière de votre part il y a une
démarche politique de votre part non
mais il y a une démarche politique de
clémentine Notin nous nous cherchons des
solutions je les dis tout à l'heure pour
rendre la vie des Français plus
acceptable
touche de nombreuses femmes c'est une
difficulté et ce texte qui a été
travaillé au Parlement européen par
Marie Dauchy qui sera repris et présenté
par le député de Camargue Emmanuel
Tachet de la Pagerie lors de notre niche
parlementaire du 12 octobre il a
vocation à reconnaître une infection
cette endométriose en affection de
longue durée ce qui est effectivement
quelque chose de très neuf mais qui
soulagera je crois beaucoup de femmes
que Madame Autun veuille faire de la
politique politicienne en disant il faut
pas que ce soit le rassemblement
national qui propose ce texte trop tard
pour les libertés
on a voté l'IVG dans la Constitution on
va pas prendre le son de Madame au thym
qui défend la Bahia et qui défend le
voile enfin écouté ce sont des
féministes en carton patte ça c'est du
concret l'endométriose on n'est pas dans
des débats intellectuels de féministes
de salon de bourgeoise féministe là on
est dans du concret et comme une
attachée de la Pagerie et quand Marie
Dauchy s'attaque à ce dossier c'est bien
pour y apporter une réponse concrète
elle peut passer du vent trop tard le
rassemblement national propose sa
disposition quiconque la votera
quiconque la reprendra demain aura
évidemment notre soutien question
politique
à Beaucaire notamment et Olivier Vérand
était passé par là juste avant vendredi
à Beaucaire précisément vous vous
retrouviez ce week-end un kiné vous y
avez eu un pied de nez non mais il y
avait pas eu de visite de ministre
depuis 9 ans je crois à Beaucaire et
Olivier Vérand ça dit tiens c'est les
universités d'été du rassemblement
national je vais aller saluer Beaucaire
Boker avec un maire élu au premier tour
Julien Sanchez qui fait un travail
remarquable je pense que cette rédaction
premier tour dit tout du travail de la
façon dont il est apprécié par ses
concitoyens donc Olivier Véran a voulu
faire de la communication comme souvent
ça se retourne lorsqu'il n'y a pas de
fond c'est l'arroser ça se retourne
envers celui qui a initié tout ça donc
Olivier Vérand s'est trouvé au milieu
des élus du rassemblement national qui
lui ont présenté toutes les réalisations
faites bancaire et je peux notamment par
exemple aussi fiscalement le fait que de
n'avoir pas augmenté les impôts d'avoir
rénové beaucoup cette ville de l'avoir
rendu attractive et bien je crois que
les viveran est reparti avec une très
bonne image de la ville de Beaucaire
peut-être qu'il n'avait pas cette bonne
image en arrivant ça lui aura au moins
servi à cela question sur les
européennes alors les européennes vous y
êtes dedans à 200 à 200% la nièce de
Marine Le Pen Marion portera les
couleurs d'Éric Zemmour à aux
européennes
est-ce que vous le regrettez je regrette
toujours que alors que nous faisons
aujourd'hui dans les sondages je vais
dire la course en tête que la liste de
Jordan Bardella les patriotes font la
course en tête et bien il y ait des
listes qui se créent pour peut-être
diviser alors à trop il y en aura trop
bah il faut en tous les cas voter utile
à une élection européenne il faut
envoyer un message clair je ne suis pas
persuadé que voter pour des listes qui
se battent pour faire 5% des voix et qui
ne les feront peut-être pas aussi le cas
républicains c'est beaucoup de chance
moi je pense qu'il faut s'unir et
j'espère qu'un jour des électeurs des
républicains des électeurs d'Éric
Zemmour des électeurs de gauche qui sont
souvenistes attachés à l'effort on
mérite au travail les électeurs est-ce
que vous appelez Marion maréchal à
l'Union non nous lui avions déjà dit
nous espérons qu'un jour elle puisse
nous rejoindre pour travailler là et il
a choisi de présenter sa liste donc elle
va aller jusqu'au bout mais il faudra un
jour que dans un premier ou dans un
second tour tous ces gens se
rejoignent la candidature ferme de
gendarmes
oui parce que la situation nécessite oui
moi je crois toujours que lorsqu'on ne
joue pas la politique du pire lorsqu'on
a uniquement l'intérêt de la France au
cœur et bien un moment on fait ce choix
de se rassembler et nous nous sommes un
mouvement politique qui a vocation a
rassembler tous les Français quel que
soit leurs origines quel que soit leurs
inclinaisons politiques qu'ils aient
voté Zemmour LR ou à gauche ils ont
vocation à nous aider dans notre projet
de redressement de la France
merci merci beaucoup notre invité ce
matin merci Fabrice bonne semaine bonne
semaine à vous on passe au club des
territoires